[Music]  damn you look good  my name is Dwayne Johnson uh I'm new to  the game and I'm so excited to be here  how are you doing I'm so glad you're  here thank you when I first saw a Black  Adam comic book and I saw the cover he  looked intense he had brown skin and he  was a superhero  I said that's my guy I want to be him  how hard was it for you to wear that  muscle suit  well first of all  we've removed the muscle padding  he's giving me the business now this is  it so when you look at that you go damn  I look good because that's what I said  damn you look good what did you say when  you looked at that I said I said damn  you look good I said the same thing  you're welcome America